[Musique]
et avec moi Jean-Michel fourgaud bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez présenté vos vœux
jeudi dernier en tant que président de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines on
va en parler dans un instant mais c'est
le maire d'Élancourt qu'on reçoit avant
tout ce soir comme tout les maires des
villes de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors si une
nouvelle année qui s'ouvre cette année
2023 mais d'abord peut-être un retour
sur l'année 2022 qui a été aussi celle
où les collectivités locales ont
commencé à faire face à la hausse du
coup de l'énergie est-ce que cette
augmentation brutale qui a pour
conséquence aussi plus tard peut-être
des baisses de dotation est-ce que ça ça
va permettre quand même la continuité de
vos projets d'investissement aussi à
Élancourt ou est-ce que ça les stoppe
oui dans la mesure où le gouvernement
arrive à négocier bien sûr le stabiliser
le prix l'énergie ce qui est fondamental
deuxièmement s'il arrive à remettre le
nucléaire qui n'aurait jamais dû être
perturbé par nos écologistes enfin je
vous rappelle que les perturbations
contre le nucléaire ça va vous coûter 50
milliards donc vous imaginez si ça ne
redescend dessus bon donc on est prudent
parce que les chiffres aujourd'hui vous
avez vu le niveau du déficit budgétaire
comme ça 600 milliards le niveau de
dettes au niveau un nouvel empreinte de
110 enfin on sent bien que l'État ne
contrôle plus ni son budget
ni les frontières
ni je dirais
la santé regardez un peu les systèmes la
sécurité
l'état il y a aucune réforme donc on
sent bien qu'on est dans une période de
non maîtrise et dans ces cas-là bien sûr
et puis en plus dans une période de
guerre entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
demain si ça s'étend du mec aujourd'hui
la mondialisation c'est ça c'est qu'il y
a deux pays qui font qui se battent
s'impact bien sûr tous l'économie
mondiale et en termes de sobriété
énergétique est-ce qu'il y a eu des
conséquences justement sur sur votre vie
des décisions à prendre bien sûr on a eu
des factures de multiplication par 5 à
10 forcément il y a eu des décisions de
réduire même encore il y a récemment les
vœux 50 ans ont été réduits pas le
moindre très au saumon pas de pas de
choses comme le foie gras ou des choses
comme ça à réduction de tout et je les
bons les coûts partout mais pour
anticiper parce que on est équilibré
bien sûr de toute façon une collectivité
c'est pas comme l'état nous on peut pas
se faire un déficit de 500 milliards oui
bon donc c'est équilibré en plus on
baisse on baisse la tête en général à
Saint-Quentin bon voilà
en tout cas j'espère que ce prix de
l'énergie ça va pas durer plus d'un an
parce que là à ce moment-là ça va mettre
des sociétés en difficulté c'est déjà le
cas faut pas se lever donc
alors même alors le problème c'est que
l'État il compense il propose mais
compenser avec quoi il est déficitaire
si l'équilibré oui c'est un sens mais si
c'est je paye mais je vous ramène ça en
impôts parce que c'est ça si il est
difficile ça veut dire qu'il vous ramène
ça en impôts vous voyez
c'est pas il y a pas de générosité là
donc voilà il faut en tout cas
responsable dire la situation de la
France aujourd'hui il faut arrêter de
raconter n'importe quoi il y a une
augmentation de la dette qui est
fracassante en 2012 il y avait il y
avait 1800 milliards de de il y avait
1800 milliards de dettes et
en la fin du mandat de Monsieur Macron
vous aurez 3600 milliards vous aurez
doublé la dette entre 2012 et 2027 il va
falloir le payer tout ça c'est les
Français qui vont le payer une dette
c'est un taux d'intérêt en plus voilà
faut dire que la situation quand même
budgétaire et très grave et c'est
toujours délicat de d'accepter un chèque
de quelqu'un qui en fait
qui en fait n'a pas d'équilibre
budgétaire il y a comme une volonté
Élancourt on sait que c'est l'image des
Yvelines c'est une ville qui a un pied
dans la ville un pied dans la campagne
aussi de de maintenir aussi ce bien-être
des habitants c'est l'une de vos
préoccupations alors par exemple sur
l'aspect environnement et l'aspect
sportif puisque vous savez qu'on a un
site olympique dans les quatre sur 50 et
en courbe on va passer de 400 km de
piste cyclables d'ailleurs vous
remarquer que nous
on parle moins d'écologie mais on en
fait plus que les écologistes faudra un
jour s'interroger sur les cellules qui
causent et qui font bon ça sert à rien
de briller sur les de raconter beaucoup
de choses voilà nous on les fait on faut
dire qu'on va être une des capitales
mondiale du vélo alors on a pas le choix
donc on passe de 400 km à 600 km bien
sûr dans les années à venir des longs
qui sera l'un des sites olympiques qui
va accueillir le VTT lui aussi on le
sait vous êtes venus d'ailleurs avec
votre petite tablette le numérique c'est
un de vos chevaux de bataille
l'éducation aussi est-ce qu'il y aura de
nouveaux projets cette année de
nouvelles choses où ça va continuer oui
alors l'éducation on a démarré et c'est
là où vous voyez l'aspect d'une
centralisation de l'État on a voilà il
faut nous faire confiance on a modifié
l'éducation à partir des lancers en
Yvelines on a modifie la pédagogie à tel
point c'est qu'on a même été invité à
l'Exposition universelle de Dubaï pour
représenter la France et pour montrer
l'innovation pédagogique aussi par les
parents par les parents par exemple par
les profs les profs
prennent plus de plaisir à
enseigner et les élèves prennent plus de
plaisir à apprendre mais bon mes chers
amis vous imaginez le succès il est et
ça s'étend toutes les villes de
Saint-Quentin mais toute la France est
en train de bien sûr de et on a eu deux
missions parlementaires bien sûr pour
expliquer ça donc ça l'éducation c'est
une réussite on va continuer on fait un
on va faire un continuum entre l'école
primaire
secondaire et jusqu'à l'université
Paris-Saclay 50 ans et une je vous
rappelle qui paraissait clé devient la
première université scientifique
mondiale en mathématiques intégration
progressive de l'UVS
très scientifique on a un modèle
éducatif très scientifique bien sûr à
Élancourt à Saint-Quentin et on a tout
le dans tout bien sûr tout Paris siècle
alors dans les grands projets il y a des
projets d'aménagement par exemple celui
du quartier des petits prix avec la
restructuration d'espace public
d'immeubles également c'est un projet de
80 millions d'euros qui va s'étendre sur
plusieurs années ce qu'on va avoir du
concret des cette année dès 2023 ah ben
alors je sais pas exactement le planning
moi par mois mais c'est une décision
budgétaire qui est actée c'est quand
même important parce que vous pouvez
prendre des tas de choses si vous avez
pas le budget on l'a ça y est les
partenaires qui suivent c'est un très
gros budget bien sûr de de rénovation
d'amélioration d'amélioration de la
qualité de vie au petit près on est très
fier on a travaillé de longues années
là-dessus il y a eu des concertations
quand même très très importantes donc
voilà c'est quelque chose qui va être
lancé dès cette année dès cette année
donc pour ce quartier des petits points
on en parlait aussi hein c'est Jeux
Olympiques qui vont arriver à l'échéance
olympique qui arrive en 2024 et ses
travaux sur la colline d'Élancourt
différents projets on l'a vu pour la
colline et donc un futur olympique pour
pour ce site ça ça débute aussi des
cette année ça a déjà débuté où est-ce
qu'on en est sur sur le dossier des
travaux alors il y a une grosse bagarre
je crois qu'avec la Savoie qui voulait
prendre
sur la colline parce qu'ils ont
effectivement des montagnes etc mais on
leur a expliqué quand même que ça se
passe tout ça au mois de juillet au mois
d'août je vois pas très bien en quoi la
neige va jouer un rôle important bon
bref mais cela dit bon on a regagné
grâce à la BBC 13h qui a dit à 1000
points sur la table a dit non c'est les
JO de Paris c'est au dérange pas les
gars bon a priori 50 ans de Ninine c'est
à moins de 30 km de Paris par
l'autoroute 100 feux rouge quasiment
puisqu'on arrive sur un encours 100 feu
rouge de Paris bon en moins de 30
minutes or encombrement bon voilà on
touche pas à ça en plus on voit Paris de
la colline d'Élancourt
point culminant derrière la Tour Eiffel
voilà donc c'est parti les travaux ont
commencé d'ailleurs
non non on est très content ça fait 30
ans qu'on qu'on se dispute tous entre
élus quelquefois pour le projet il y a
une des grands débat machin là bon a
priori que tout le monde est une anime
sur le fait que les JO plus gros
événements mondial tout le monde s'est
rangé derrière ce projet et franchement
on est très content avec un site qui
sera ouvert bien sûr aux habitants à la
suite on parle de cyclisme justement le
tracé du Tour de France va partir du
vélodrome de 50 ans en Yvelines pour la
dernière étape sur cette année 2023 il
va passer aussi à Élancourt ce tracé du
Tour de France pour la dernière étape
alors on apprend ça on a pris ça bien
sûr le département c'est grâce au
département merci d'ailleurs sur le fait
d'avoir la dernière le dernier départ la
dernière étape du Tour de France qui
part du vélo du vélo Drôme donc les
cheveux clairs
spectaculaire ou c'est en plus est un
totem quasiment on devient totem en
terme de sport et autre chose puisque on
a vu que même la plus grosse notoriété
qu'on ait eu sur 50 ans en Yvelines dans
les événements on pensait que c'était la
rigueur Cup c'était c'était
on apprend voilà mais tant mieux hein
mais de toute façon le maximum il est
devenu en fait le le premier centre
médical
en cas d'urgence contre la pandémie donc
oui aujourd'hui il a demain demain si on
a une autre pandémie on a une réactivité
encore plus forte bien sûr en France
voilà donc ça sert aussi c'est au vélo
etc tu vois ça va être très médiatisé
pendant
je crois que le vélodrome est classé
dans un des sites qui va être le plus
médiatisé encore que également le VTT va
être original en plus le projet est beau
hein
regarde ça ils sont enchantés d'abord il
voit que les élus enfin ce sont mis
d'accord sur un projet depuis 30 ans
c'est rassure autant ce sujet alors
l'autre projet aussi qui va prendre
Corse cette année c'est celui du
commissariat d'agglomération qui doit
voir le jour dans la zone des 4 arbres
c'est un projet que vous portez depuis
une dizaine d'années pareil ce qui est
d'une nouveau du concret sur ce dossier
la même chose dans lequel la
décentralisation laissons les
collectivités
s'occuper des des choses de proximité
comme ça ça fait 10 ans qu'on se bat
avec l'administration on je crois que
mon cellier c'est réglé on a mais oui on
finance rendez compte un peu c'est au
collectivités de financer première
mission à guérienne de l'État parce que
il y a plus d'argent on vous le dit pas
mais il y a plus d'argent regardez les
médecins tout le monde gueule etc mais
pourquoi parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens
de désormais les médecins il faut le
dire allez voir dans une version du tout
ils jouent pour on n'aura pas plus de
médecins parce qu'il y a plus l'argent
ça coûte cher de faire un médecin donc
il faut produire de la richesse il faut
augmenter la production de richesse
c'est que demain si je disais
syndicaliste je disais mais vous voulez
qu'on vous demande votre salaire et ben
les gars vous mettez au niveau allemand
vous aviez le même niveau de production
de richesse il y a quelques années ben
vous reprenez le même niveau de
production des chaises mais vous adaptez
aussi un peu avec les règles du jeu et
si vous avez le même niveau moi je vous
augmente vos salaires de 20 %. donc
dites-vous bien une chose que tout ça on
va régler nos problèmes si on augmente
simplement si on passe de 67% d'actifs
qui bossent
à 77 comme les Allemands mais je peux
vous dire il y a plus de problèmes de
retraite il y a plus de problèmes
d'équilibre du budget et là on retrouve
un système sain et c'est la solution
pour pour réformer le service public la
santé l'éducation la police qui manque
cruellement de moyens donc en tout cas
ce projet de sécurité du futur puisque
même le ministre interne dit bien que
c'est il y a beaucoup de commissaires
qui se construisent mais le seul qui a
le label commissaire du futur c'est
effectivement
bien sûr très avec toutes les
technologies donc voilà c'est vous
connaissez la culture numérique et la
culture numérique de Saint-Quentin est
très forte et bien sûr sert à ce projet
bien sûr donc c'est cette année pour le
début des travaux du coup c'est pas
encore ça démarre dans quelques mois ça
démarre le budget est là bien sûr et non
ça y est essayé tout le monde est pas
prêt d'accord mais 10 ans
des projets s'il faut 10 ans à chaque
fois il va falloir simplifier les lois
et on l'a enfin on l'a montré encore
récemment on veut il faut que les gens
comprennent qu'on peut pas la France ne
peut pas garder une culture
administrative aussi
paralysante c'est pas possible on peut
pas freiner une initiative sportive ou
économique comme cela donc de toute
façon il faut changer ce pays il faut il
faut lui faire confiance aux
collectivités je pense il faut il faut
insuffler une culture entrepreneuriale
beaucoup plus forte il faut que le
processus des signaux il y a des chefs
d'entreprise et des administratifs on
veut pas comme ça abandonner tout le
système de décision politique française
uniquement à une classe il faut arrêter
ça il faut des gens il faut les doubles
cultures il faut la double culture très
rapidement est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
projets alors tout début d'année
l'inauguration de terrain de nos
terrains de tennis aussi à Élancourt ça
fait partie des projets qui voient le
jour est-ce que il y en a un autre que
vous souhaitez mettre en avant alors
celui il faut tout se dire le terrain de
tennis ben de toute façon on était
obligé d'abord il était un peu obsolète
il faut le dire et puis de toute façon
le projet de commissariat arrivant voilà
il fallait bon donc il fallait de ça
dans le déplacer donc en le déplaçant on
le modernisait donc effectivement il y a
un très beau un très bel ensemble de
pour le tennis aujourd'hui et qui permet
aussi de faire arriver le le fameux
commissariat de Saint-Quentin Lille qui
va être un écommissariats de France et
on termine cette entretien Jean-Michel
Franco savait qu'il y a l'interview
express
[Musique]
alors le principe 5 questions des
réponses courtes on a posé les mêmes
questions à l'ensemble des mers qui sont
venus sur ce plateau au cours du mois de
janvier parfois quelques explications je
vais vous demander s'il y a une
explication en 20 secondes maximum
première question Jean-Michel fourgaud
c'est ce qu'en 2023 vous augmenterez les
impôts locaux et en cours écoutez les
impôts dans les 10 dernières années
c'était 35% d'augmentation au niveau
national et nous on était 17
c'est-à-dire deux fois moins maintenant
je ne prendrai aucune
aucun engagement devant mes électeurs ou
alors il me disent que la guerre est
terminée il me disent que le nucléaire
on revient à 80% et non pas 40 avec qui
est quand même la meilleure garantie
qu'on est sur le sur l'impact des coûts
d'énergie sur nos budget voilà si une
garantissage leur garantie que
j'augmente pas mais
voilà on fouette sérieux on peut pas
prendre moi vous savez je j'ai baissé
les impôts même 50 ans je me suis quand
même de 25% c'est assez rare quand même
je suis plutôt
quand même voilà faut pas prendre
d'engagement je pense qu'il faut faire
confiance à son maire je pense que les
maires sont les élus les plus chéris par
les Français je pense qu'il y a des
raisons d'ailleurs ce qui sont de
proximité donc voilà c'est des gens
sérieux donc gardons confiance mais je
prendrai pas l'engagement dessus même si
on fait du bio selon mais voilà on voit
pas on va pas augmenter au-delà on
respecte la loi là-dessus on l'a vu dans
l'actualité malheureusement des maires
des élus victimes d'agression de menaces
est-ce que dans l'exercice de vos
fonctions vous êtes déjà senti menacés
oui on a on a des gestes d'incivilité de
certains jeunes m'ont le le plus c'est
bien ça c'est sur Trab dès qu'on cesser
quand même un territoire très
particulier
où il faut effectivement je crois qu'il
faut réexpliquer les valeurs de la
République les valeurs de respect tout
ça il y a tout un travail à faire mais
en dehors non pas Élancourt mais Messi
mes collègues me le disent enfin moi
j'ai eu j'ai des trois fois agressé mais
à Paris oui paradoxalement il faut le
faire
pas Élancourt non et
je crois qu'on a été classé dans une des
villes les plus sûres dans les 10 villes
les plus sûrs je crois dans une étude
qui parlait dans Le Parisien je crois
des Yvelines bon et que on travaille et
a priori si demain vous avez le
commissariat il permet voilà à Élancourt
pour 50 ans Yvelines je pense que les
élans encore toi vont à faire des effets
secondaires plutôt positifs
d'aider les gens de de leur faire gagner
du temps de leur faire gagner de la
qualité de la vie de veiller leur
pouvoir d'achat selon le contexte bien
sûr
d'améliorer le modèle éducatif
d'améliorer la sécurité
de de les prix de fleurissement enfin on
a 54 je relisais on a 54 repris les
labels à Élancourt oui l'équipe est
motivée il se sentent bien ils sont
fiers et on le voit bien il y a un
sentiment d'appartenance des élans
courtois et de mes collaborateurs qui
est bon et j'ai pas de départ de mes
collaborateurs je veux dire que c'est
c'est
merci Jean-Michel fourgousse
merdéencourt président de 50 ans en
Yvelines et très bonne année 2023 dans
votre ville et votre agglomération merci
beaucoup
[Musique]